my name is Willie Wonka how do you feel
about Timothy shalamay playing Willie
Wonka in the upcoming Wonka movie is
there anyone else you'd rather see Dawn
the famous purple suit plenty of folks
on the internet have shared their own
opinions about this casting as well as
who they'd rather see take over the
iconic Chocolate Factory thanks to AI we
could see what all of these fantasy
wonkers would actually look like when
Timothy shalamay was first announced as
the newest actor to take on the famous
role of Willie Wonka there was one actor
in particular that fans were saying they
could have easily imagined snagging the
part Jeremy Allen White plays car me on
the hit FX dramedy the bear he took on
the role after a long run as lip
Gallagher on the Showtime series
Shameless it's clear that white is an
actor with a lot of talent and a massive
fan base but these weren't the traits
that made folks on the internet think he
was a Sho in for the role of a young
Willie Wonka rather than a classic
remake Wonka is more like a prequel of
this film so some people were hoping to
see a version of young Willy Wonka in
this movie that looked like he could
actually grow up to be Jean Wilder's
version of Willie Wonka one day once
folks suggested that Jeremy Allen White
definitely fit into this category the
internet couldn't stop thinking about
just how much he looked like a young
Jean Wilder Dwayne Johnson AKA The Rock
is probably one of the last people you'd
imagine as Willie Wonka but believe it
or not he almost played the role in
Instagram post Johnson recalled being
considered by director Tim Burton for
the leading role in his 2005 remake
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory it's
clear based on his post that he was
definitely interested in the role of
course though It ultimately went to
Johnny Depp Johnson wrote quote the fact
that Tim even considered me albe it I'm
sure he considered for all of 7 Seconds
sure meant a hell of a lot to me as I
was just breaking into the business with
no idea what the future had in store it
definitely would have been surprising to
see such a buff version of wily Wonka
and it sounds like it worked out for the
best but we'll admit we're pretty
freaked out by seeing the rock with hair
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia fans
might be just as surprised to see
Charlie day as Willie wona as we were to
see the rock with hair memes of the star
in his yellow suit performing the day
man musical in the sitcom were making
the rounds on the internet when news
broke about Wonka folks suggested that
day could play the role and and it's
true He's Got The Whimsy and musical
theater chops the role requires and it's
clear he'd sport the legendary Wonka
suit well the flash star Ezra Miller has
also been mentioned as a fan favorite
choice for the role but the Myriad
recent controversies surrounding the
actor made the casting unlikely even so
we can totally see the resemblance to
Johnny Depp's version of the character
in this image we'd be surprised to see
Tao yti taking on playing Willie Wonka
as his next career move surprisingly
though we will be seeing the actor
director and Writer's take on the iconic
character soon enough the Academy Award
winner has two different animated
Netflix series in the works one is based
on R doll's novel Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory and the other will
focus on the famous Oompa loomas one
actor who had fans interested for the
titular role in Wonka is Mad Max Fury
Road Star Nicholas Holt and the reason
behind the fantasy casting is an
interesting one fans wanted to bring the
actor back together with his About a Boy
co-star Hugh Grant who will star in
Wonka as an noal Lupa if you thought
Ryan Reynolds was the actor who scored
the coveted role you're not alone a
viral deep fake version of Reynolds as
Wonka sparked rumors online but this was
as Wonka himself would say Pure
Imagination one casting idea that wasn't
imagination Tom Holland Holland and
shalam were the final two actors being
considered for the role before it was
given into shalam like shalam Holland is
the perfect age for a young Wonka plus
his history of singing and dancing in
past credits made him a fit for the role
as did his proven ability to make an
iconic character his own just like he
did with Spider-Man like Tom Holland
Miles Teller is a big star of the moment
who has some musical Talent at his
disposal as an upand cominging leading
man taking on the role of Wonka would
have allowed The Talented star to show
off a new side and we think he could
have pulled it off if you've seen lame M
Rob then you know Eddie redm can do
musicals plus this Academy award-winning
actor has proven time and time again
that he has the chops to not only fit
the fantasy genre but also to embody
many different types of characters and
he pulls off the purple suit perfectly
be honest would you have preferred one
of these versions of Willie Wonka over
Timothy shalamay are you looking forward
to Wonka we want to hear all about it in
the comments and be sure to like And
subscribe to the thing for more videos
like this
one